[Music]
in our earlier grades we have studied
motion and its types let's have a quick
review let's start with motion in simple
words if a body is moving it's described
as motion that's all in slightly more
technical words motion is defined as a
change in the position of a body with
time yes change in the position with
time for example when an object is
moving from point A to point B it's
changing its position with time we saw
that the time is also changing along
with the position so it is undergoing
motion what are the types of motion that
we had studied previously we have seen
four types of motion the simplest of all
is the rectilinear motion it is the
motion of a body in a straight line the
example that we saw earlier is of a
rectilinear motion object is moving in a
straight line from A to B there is
another type of motion called a circular
motion
what can this type of motion be it is
the motion of a body along the
circumference of a circle example motion
of the earth around the Sun is an
example of circular motion the third
type of motion that we saw is a
rotational motion it is the motion of a
body around a fixed axis which is
passing through the object this is
important the axis has to pass through
the object example of rotational motion
is a ceiling fan rotating along its axle
so you see that if I draw a hypothetical
line called the axis of rotation then
it's passing through the fan and the
final type of motion is a periodic
motion which is the motion that repeats
itself in equal intervals of time can
you think of any example of this type of
motion any object repeating its motion
in equal intervals of time will be
undergoing periodic motion assume an
object is moving in circles and is
covering each round every 3 seconds
is it performing a pure
motion absolutely since it's repeating
its motion along the same path every
three seconds it is undergoing periodic
motion but wait a moment this object is
moving along the circumference of a
circle so it is also undergoing circular
motion so what can you conclude from
this example we can say that an object
can undergo more than one type of motion
at the same time here are the few of the
examples of motion in our everyday life
go through them well and tell me what
type of motion each one of them
represents and note that one example
could also have more than one type of
motion the first one is clearly
rectilinear motion it's a car moving
along a straight line the second one is
interesting most of us would have
guessed rectilinear motion after seeing
the word straight which type of motion
are the wheels of an automobile
performing are they undergoing
rotational motion or rectilinear motion
or both since the automobile is moving
in a straight line
it's wheels are undergoing both
rectilinear and rotational motion at the
same time what about the simple pendulum
we know that a simple pendulum performs
to and fro motion this to and fro motion
repeats itself in equal intervals of
time so it's undergoing periodic motion
now let me ask you a question suppose
you want to travel to city B from city a
which mode of transport will get you
quicker to the destination a bicycle or
an aeroplane obviously an aeroplane
because the speed of an aeroplane in air
is much quicker than the speed of a
bicycle on a road but what is speed keep
watching our videos to know more
[Music]